this is actually based on a question
that is in the exercise that I did not
assign at least I don't think I did I
didn't attention because I want to show
you now okay have a look
Pascal's triangle I have highlighted two
of the numbers in Pascal's triangle I
saw what it appears at random now humor
me please
one plus three what's it equal cool
that's a classic good all right now this
time I've just moved it down a bit
three plus six nine
10 plus 6
and then and then and do you need okay
so mystery patent right now here's the
thing right now that we know because of
our definition for what NCR is which can
we remember and see uh what's it equal
to again on toriel fantastic okay
Cedric your passion and conviction since
we night is we've never been able to
take advantage of that to nourish why
the patents or at least some of the
patterns in Pascal's triangles are what
they are for instance the one we looked
at last time I think was these um crying
Rose a pass was prime time we're like
they do a weird thing and we worked out
why they did a weird thing based nice
definition okay so this pattern I just
showed you of these guys these guys
these guys these guys in solar right I
should be able to work out why do they
do that through its mechanism I want you
to think about it let me rewind a little
bit I started for all the way up here
okay
and then what I did was I migrated down
in a diagonal why this so I want you to
think I want you to think what is it
that binds all of these pairs of numbers
together how would you describe them
they are all turn to because room this
is time 0 then turn 1 then turn two so
this is also 0 and then 1 then 2 which
makes all the other ones right time I'm
2 2 2 2 2 and so on yes okay good
this is where we're going to start so I
can say there are two terms I'm adding
they're both something C 2 plus
something else
C - yes now the thing that we notice
which is cool is you can do this in any
row you like right all the way down so I
can say the nth row but then the next
number down is gonna be in the n plus 1
row
ok these are the two objects and we
notice every time there's square number
so I'm going to pause there for me and
saying with this what could you do to
prove not just observe and say huh
that's cool but to prove that this must
be the case we can always get a square
number I'm gonna leave you with this as
a start
see how far you can get off you go this
is a proof question you're trying to
demonstrate that this thing always gives
you some kind of square but you don't
know too much about that square so I
should point out with Pascal's triangle
one of you you can actually work out
what square you get every single time as
you proceed down and you can work out
what you're supposed to get on the
right-hand side so you know where you're
going but in case you're still flowering
a little bit let me help you out the
first step has to be to translate this
which is just shorthand really for what
it really is all this factorial stuff
okay
so help me do
the left-hand side and convert it into a
factorial notation can you just help me
do that
yes listen okay sir in factorial n minus
2 cool so that's a good start then
you've got another binomial coefficient
but it's not on the enthrone it's on
verb and US wife were right it was first
M plus 1 I think anyway so therefore on
the numerator you've got it was one cool
- no no now at this point you should be
careful right this number is this
technology right this take away this so
therefore this will be this take away
this n plus 1 take away 2 right so
that's going to wire it's going to be n
minus 1 cool ok just be watching watch
out for your pluses and minuses in
numbers that increment like that okay
now remember I'm expecting something
that is swag so I'm just gonna cross my
fingers that start to simplify out and
see what emerges we have a look at this
this is a literally a textbook unroll
the factorial question isn't it what
would you just do with this
you can unroll this guy right
this has more terms in it than this it
has exactly two more terms in it right
what are those two terms there's gonna
be an end and then there's gonna be n
minus one right now after that it's n
minus 2 factorial but I'm not even going
to write that you're starting to get a
little more comfortable with this I'm
just going to cancel it straight away
are you okay with that you see what I've
done the N minus 2 factorial M would
have written here has cancer with the 1
in the denominator I mean I can't write
n minus 2 factorial twice by one so he
was there but the whole point of writing
is to cancel oh so I'm just gonna go
straight there are you comfortable okay
I can do the same thing on the other
fraction ah good question in this case
and I admit it's uh only for this case
actually no it's not just this case for
one makes the same to two factorial of
course is two times one which is two so
in this case I can't just yeah so it's
not like the factorial disappear I
actually evaluated it does that make
sense
same thing with one and that's it every
other number is something different okay
on the right hand side or the right a
fraction rather I can do the same thing
here do you know this this has exactly
two more terms in it than this what are
the two terms
and plus 1 and then n okay now I find
way to wipe the rest of this it would
then be n minus 1 factorial but the
whole point of me unrolling it is the
cancel with this gun so I'm not gonna
write it I'm just gonna cancel it right
okay right and and I also evaluate this
is your faction okay I'm almost there
I've already gotten common denominator
that's convenient so I've got N squared
minus n over there and then I've got N
squared plus n over there do you agree
all over 2 this is going to cancel with
this that lease period 2n squared on to
which low involved it had better always
be a square okay so you can see when
you're willing to look at the machinery
of this right the magic of Pascal's
triangle magic is actually quote from
this famous Indian mathematician and he
said you know things are magic until you
understand them and then they're
mathematics